our commitment the commitment of the
federal government to be here with you
as you continue to go through this road
to recovery
um and since our work began here we have
witnessed exemplary leadership from
across the community that the local
leaders fire leaders the community
leaders and what you have done to bring
the communities together and give them
the resources that they need
the emergency managers and first
responders we've asked so much of them
in
the last few years in response to
covid19 yet they still show up and are
providing just amazing service to their
communities
sacrificing time with their families who
may be impacted to make sure that their
communities continue to stay safe
when we began receiving reports of the
devastation that these tornadoes were
going to bring and we quickly sent teams
forward to make sure that we would be
able to provide the support that you
needed governor in order to save as many
lives as we could we deployed emergency
response teams
from across the nation uh these
multi-jurisdictional multi-disciplinary
teams to come in and assist the ex
amazing efforts that the local and the
state responders were already doing in
their rescue operations
these teams
worked side by side day and night to
make sure that they could
find survivors
and their actions were heroic they were
selfless and required such a significant
amount of trust of people that may have
not met each other before in order to
make sure that they were helping these
communities
and as you heard the secretary say in
the days following a disaster we know
that communications are a struggle and
that it's hard for individuals to to get
the resources that they need that's why
in addition to the disaster recovery
centers that the secretary mentioned we
also have the disaster survivor
assistance teams they are out in the
communities right now they have ipads
with them they're wearing fema shirts
and they'll be able to help you either
register for assistance or direct you to
other resources that you might need so
if you see somebody in a fema shirt
walking around your community please
stop them and ask them for assistance if
you need additional help
with the president's signing of the
major disaster declaration on december
12th we also have individual assistance
that's been authorized for the
communities that have been designated
this will help individuals secure
temporary lodging
start to rebuild their homes and begin
assisting with their recovery efforts
but i'd like to point out that fema is
just one part of this team we're a small
part of this team and we bring the
entire federal family together to come
help with this recovery process
i mean it's really supporting the
amazing efforts that are already
underway at the state level and the
local level
and it's this whole of community
approach
that is really going to be able to
provide this road to recovery for those
that have been impacted and that work
has already begun
and we're seeing as you heard neighbors
helping neighbors businesses helping
businesses
i've seen community partners cooking on
the streets helping to feed those that
have been impacted by this
debris is already being hauled off the
sites that have been damaged the power
is coming back online this is recovery
beginning and we will be with you
throughout this recovery progress and so
just know that we are with you and our
hearts are with you thank you governor
thank you
you